foreign
[Applause]
I was at that phase in my life where I
was trying to make that list you know
that list of how many people have I been
with oh so of that list oh yeah so in
order to figure it out I wrote
everybody's name down on a piece of
paper I then left that piece of paper at
your house
did you ever come across it
well you know as a matter of fact I've
been meaning to talk to you about this
[Applause]
some of the names on that before we move
on I want to give you something that I
found in our house like a really long
time ago
it's called duplex story ideas
but then on the back it says Drew's list
so I just wanted to give that back to
you since you have
it's your lady mouth
[Laughter]
you know this from the book we talk
about poop quite a bit
yeah is it okay to talk about yeah you
just drop the p word okay right in the
middle everybody does it yeah everybody
does and if you're if you're not doing
it that's an angry person we need to
normalize talking about going to the
bathroom yeah we do and normal as far as
frequency and formation is is one to
three snakes a day really yeah Bristol
chart so if you're not going one to
three snakes a day your body's telling
you something oh okay God it starts with
fiber the fiber is providing your body
the nutrients here but your microbiome
needs which is all the trillions of
bacteria in your gut I
snakes it's like it's such a visual
thing I'm just looking at it now yeah
garter snake or boa oh my God look at
this amazing outfit and look well here
let me keep it real with you yeah that
happened I guess I've been eating my
stress a little bit lately and I have to
have like a brassiere thing put in there
so I'm gonna reevaluate my life this
weekend just dealing with a mic pack
issue and I haven't shaved my legs in
like six months
I also don't moisturize so it's like a
bearded dragon with hair down here so
that's attractive
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm not so like we could compare
um
[Applause]
by the way touching your leg you are
shaved okay that's good to know
there's a little bit of but it's fine no
no no it's it's pure as the driven snow
okay great it's perfect this is a whole
different ball game do you want to shave
often like no it took me three months to
finally get to shave yes and I was so
it's like I feel like I
like I had a full-blown movie makeover
just by that me too put on my underwear
backwards oh did not realize it until I
like go to use the bathroom in public
and I'm like my underwear and back do
you wear a big girl underwear like I
wear big girl underwear like as in like
there's the underwear themselves they're
a big girl they're they're big they're
they're they're Hefty they're they're
they're they're girthy they're like you
could use it as a parachute in an
emergency I have so hot I think I'm
having one of my first perimenopause hot
flashes for the first time I think I'm
having my first hot flash
I feel so honored
how uh flight attendants feel about the
mile high club oh
I think you know if that doesn't know
how they feel about that that teeny tiny
bathroom's a rocking are you a member of
that club of the mile high club
no I am not no uh uh you are aren't you
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
did you just change your hair color or
is it just the lighting it looks so good
now same same color
[Applause]
we could all use some common etiquette
advice and I take etiquette very
seriously just take a look
oh my God
[Music]
I want to spread this all over myself
[Applause]
[Music]
I'd say let's taste but clearly I'm
finished with mine
all right
can I ask you a question
well that's the thing I don't want to
what do I do if I don't want this piece
of food in my mouth oh
so
um a lot of the time well show me how
you would do it what if I just did this
yeah
[Applause]
thank you
I cannot believe
don't look over look away look away
[Music]